okay so I'm not gonna be much of a
moderator I am not even going to be
seated among you so I think maybe it
would be helpful to see if there are
questions among you for each other as a
starting point and then we'll just open
it for for general conversation and
again in I hope I'm somebody who comes
from a tradition of like you hand people
written questions index cards and I'm
going to the drugstore at some point and
buy a big packet of index cards so that
those can be forwarded pardon me I think
for future it helps to have indexes so
there's no repetition but just so it
makes for a certain efficiency of time
to be able to condense questions or make
sure there's no
so I have the question okay I have a
question so my question is there is a
big debate in Canada right now so just
FYI Canadian EHR does not have race okay
which as an American who had a child in
the UK also right I I was like it took
20 minutes for the doctors to convince
me that there was no race like I said oh
it's in another database he said no it
doesn't exist I said no it's it's
recorded secretly by like the federal
got no it doesn't exist it does not
exist it is not recorded anywhere this
is terrifying to me as a machine
learning researcher because even though
I don't want to use race as a social as
a like biological category and predict
things in specific race buckets I need
to be able to audit my model and say
that it does equally well in people of
different races what what are you but
that's sort of it like ml hat on like
like the thought process what do you
guys think there's a serious
conversation right now about do we
include it
do we not include it what is its place
in the electronic health care record
so this is a comfort discussion that
happens in a lot of countries so one
thing is to move outside of the US
framing thinking that the u.s. is like
normalization number one number two so
for example also you have to understand
the political history of my countries
don't so France for example because what
happened in World War two and who was
rounded up and sent to the death camps
so that's why they have no data in their
administrative systems if you want to
include racial I think data and a Health
Study their respective protocols would
go through to be able to develop the
data set they would do that precisely
because of the misuse of race ethnicity
and we're about to see in the US with
the way in the u.s. there was the case
of the Japanese in World War two where
again there was a violation of US law
around the u.s. census about what number
of years did I have access to individual
records that was violated to be able to
pick up Japanese
so there it's again first understanding
politically why country does or doesn't
have those categories secondly if it's
your research purposes what's done in
terms of the then the other question is
is is understanding if you don't assess
if you don't have the access what do you
what is done to be able to gain access
for the purposes of research only that
don't follow people but if you if it is
baked into the data the way that we have
it denies to look at it both a
critically as the category and B to
realize that it's only picking up one
bit of what the variables are and what
are the other people were thinking about
Toronto segregation in relation to both
race ethnicity Nativity immigration
histories and also income levels so it's
always not it's not it's that's a
variable but it's starting it's the
beginning of a conversation with the
data not the end of it so it's not
seeing it as a shortcut that would do
more than it ought to so but to
understand why these are political
contests is that there's a real history
behind it and a history with genocide
well I would just add to that that the
question is what is race being used for
in the research and how is it being
defined so there's a lot of research
that goes on in the United States where
race is used as a variable
without any definition of what it means
who belongs to how they decide who is in
that category and an assumption that
it's a biological category but if you
assume instead that it is what it really
is a political category and you are
using it in order to understand identify
measure and end racism then use it that
way but you have to figure out then how
how do I use it that in my decide for
that particular purpose a lot of times
race is being
is a proxy for something else this is
true in medicine you know you ask doctor
why are you using race to treat this
patient aren't there more important
things and they'll say yeah there are
more important things but I don't have
time or it's easy to use race arms talk
to these race and my answer to that is
use the more important variable but when
it comes to racism race is the important
variable so it it really I think for all
of us whatever kind of researchers we
are being more careful about what this
term means and how we're using it is
it's really important and as Nancy said
it's it's political so you know it's a
completely we're using it for political
purposes and to acknowledge that and
really criticize and explore and
interrogate what those political
purposes are is important to say one
other thing about ok we might think for
example that citizenship is an important
category for the census but we now know
that the Trump administration wants to
add it in order to deny voting rights so
you know that again the what is it being
used for because of that I might
ordinarily in another context say oh
yeah I think that's an important
question no when the United States today
no I want it I don't want it in the
census because I know what it's
first time neglected to say that we do
have publications in artwork my former
post up would be very upset what I said
but the book includes so much more than
we can't do it in an article just to
clarify nothing I'm gonna get played for
this but so yeah I agree with what but I
would recommend that you talk to
pathetic seamen who is in Paris and they
are he's also working with the WHL and
other part at UN he as he has proposed
to use race categories in France he has
been treated like persona non grata
because because you just don't do it you
do not do it but but he wants to measure
discrimination yes he's a sociologist
and he wants to measure discrimination
and so it's been a war and I think it
might be interesting for given your
concerns for you to talk to him and what
the situation is there so I'll connect
you okay and connecting these two
comments just question some issues of
racism in the health systems so that the
exposure variable is racism for which
you do need to have data on race
ethnicity in terms of who is being
targeted in what ways but it's not so
it's it's that the individual level
variable is the start of the
conversation but it's only the start
because you need to get all the other
kinds of variables and it would be easy
to go on at great length about what the
many measures are that are available at
different levels
I wanted to ask you because I I saw Emma
your student give I love that paper I
think it's fantastic what he I mean
you're an economist like what do you
think about races inclusion and the
separation because I think actually if
that paper is one of the examples of why
I would want it recorded for the audit
yeah and without answering actually
counts this question - Cynthia is it
seems an eminently unfair bounce to you
but the bill don't everyone also saying
it seems like the use case dictates the
data collection the research use case
has very easy money sorry the use case
dictates data collection the research
use case has properties that we wouldn't
that make easier to collect data than
all the other cases and I feel like your
work is highlighted a little bit this
issue that you can easily imagine trying
to collect data but we can do audits
with very noisy measures of race you can
make the measures of race parity this is
a simple pose when we went to collect
data there was a hard wire noise enough
of the Rings very you can structure the
noise in such a way that for purposes of
audits of any other malfeasance using it
those those techniques have been used
for other things and people proposed
them and so on it I'm curious whether
you or others know try because it seems
I mean I'm not saying it's feasible but
at least it's on the boundary of
proposal
another way outside to you that's just
unfair you don't have that that's a I
haven't heard that specific proposal
before but there are a variety of
cryptographic techniques that could come
into play here and I think it should be
a really fruitful direction for not just
for investigation I think that in theory
there are very good solutions so that's
very intriguing let's throw it open to
the audience I actually do have index
cards but no easy distribution system
yet so I think for future sessions I'll
position them in some way that will be
announced but in the meantime so I just
wanted to ask about if it's in kind of
seeing all the talks if it's a fair to
say a main message of this being namely
that
because I haven't seen it stated as a
main message I've seen a lot of problems
be stated so I just want to check if
this is fair to say that we can't silo
off any of the math ever when talking
about things were going to deploy into
the world we can't separate it off and
say okay we're going to talk about the
math now there are many things we will
always miss and that we need to always
have some the marginalized communities
as part of the decision-making process I
guess when you were saying that well it
seems maybe if we just have someone from
that knows algorithms and someone from
health care then we're covered but if
you have someone from our healthcare
system which is kind of this
individualistic system then we don't
have the communities that we need at the
table when talking about this so I guess
where I'm coming from is like a
complexity theory we talk about we talk
about things very abstractly we talk
about something called worst-case
analysis and when you want to talk about
things that happen in the real world you
need to talk about how are the instances
distributed you need to get really
specific and we can brush that away
because you know complexity theory its
importance is many degrees down the line
whereas this it feels like there's much
more responsibility to be correct right
now if we're putting stuff out into the
world so I just want to ask can I say a
main message of this is that we need to
be very instant specific any specific
for a specific problem that we're
dealing with I'm talking about health
care maybe carcere ality maybe whatever
I need to be ok I'm doing this specific
task with this specific objective
function let me find the specific people
it will the marginalize people that will
affect and bring them into the
discussion
I think that that's true for any
application area if you want to work in
that area you should have a
understanding of the system that
generated the data you'll work on one
thing that I think is helpful is in in
the machine so you know for computer
science students right often they get
interested in an application area
because they they participate in a
challenge of some kind right and one of
the things I really liked at last nurse
which is a big machine learning
conference that happens in December is
there was a Google inclusive images
challenge team at Google spent a ton of
time and effort to acquire photographs
from around the world many different
diverse locations have users tagged this
is what a wedding looks like in India so
stop classifying my wedding as
performance art in google images this is
real it's classified as performance art
right now so but they they took the time
and the effort to create that data set
and make labels and a bunch of people
participated in that data set challenge
right and so now there's a lot of
students and professors who say well
there's data there this is an
interesting topic I'd like to engage
with this right and so I think having
people who have some subject matter
knowledge make easy entry points so that
you can understand oh there's all of
this complexity there's all of this this
difference it's really valuable are you
talking as as somebody who's creating
algorithms yes part of it was some of
the talks are depressing in the sense of
okay besides just being depressing it's
like okay what next then what do we do
and I feel like a lot of computer
scientists can be like okay what are the
general rules I can make that will work
always and what I'm getting from the
talks are there are not no such ones you
need to bring in those specific
marginalized people to talk about the
overall context
so the one quick comment is I'm very
supportive of what you're saying but
there's two things to hear one is that
it's not like people who are quote
unquote marginalize oh so so it's real
and and the other point is that it's all
of our responsibilities to learn the
history that's relevant I'm a teacher
and I believe people can learn and
that's why I teach it's my
responsibility as a white person born in
United States to know deeply a lot of
the very bad history of the US and also
the really good history of people trying
to make it with up to what the original
promises so in terms of indigenous
rights and let Joseph so so it's so it's
never it can't just be put on the
marginalized people and it's about and
also recognizing again real differences
and real political fights and fights
over turf and money are also very active
so not to have that be somehow like
there's a unified community there but
not to take away from the responsibility
of all of us to know that deeply the
history engaged in that and yes context
specific I would also say that I mean
one of the things that we're pushing for
at least at my university is is
interdisciplinary collaborations a lot
of times it's just talk but there is
some real sincere effort and I think
that if you actually work with people in
in other fields and disciplines I think
you're you know you'll produce something
that is much richer and useful and
hopefully not harmful so I highly
recommend that and that also means
changing the structure of credit in a in
academic work and we need to change that
too that is I think slowly changing but
but we need to work on that so that so
if you look at the do us big data
studies or unfortunately some of the
socio genomics big data studies you'll
see you
huge author lists and they've figured
out a way so that everyone can get
credit and so you know learn from that
so that you will get credit for your
work but you won't you'll also get the
advantage of collaborative point out
that your question is a great question
and it touches on a couple things one is
what is the knowledge that's going into
the creation of these algorithms what
what are what are the assumptions who
can can test those assumptions where do
they come from you know the politics
we've all been talking about it but it
also raises the question of who has
authority to create them in the first
place
and that I think we've touched on you
know with the people who are gonna be
affected by them which disciplines are
going to control that you know that's
another political question and they're
related but they're two different
aspects that are really important I'm
glad you you brought that up yeah I I
think I agree with most everything
you've said that I felt like you've
emitted something which is also super
important that is I think you described
luckily there's an example it's not like
the frameworks and complexity theory was
born overnight it took time for people
to realize what were the abstractions
and features are was irrelevant and went
from decidability
saying run time then state space matters
that is the evolution of the theory as
it starts to get a sense of which
abstractions are relevant and which
abstractions we absorb and leave besides
I think it's just important to realize
there are really fundamental questions
here
which is okay so then what is a good
model what abstraction should be built
what will generalize so I share your
spirit of saying oh wow
this is a very rough terrain but I don't
necessarily agree that where this ends
up is in a bad place this is what makes
our a young student I'd be excited this
is where interesting theoretical
frameworks are built building it is
going to be hard so many question builds
on this I think I'd like I'm over here
I'd like to ask imagine that the people
who are here could build the
certification of responsible ml or
algorithmic use and I heard at least six
characteristics tell me if I'm correct
about this but there might be more
the first is anything that is solely
relying on data that is individualized
is inadequate there has to be systemic
ecological second is that there has to
be scrutinizing constantly of proxies
that are implicit including cost of
health race - anything etc so there's
this collision that happens a lot the
third is that there needs to be studies
or factors of racism rather than race so
that's one form of the structural the
fourth is that there needs to be some
kind of rebuilding of anything that call
is called genomic and anything called
genomic should not be used because it's
actually built on a set of assumptions
that are disguised and I guess there's a
question there is that beyond genomics
is that beyond gene wasps is that to
some other data sets that are also
problematic and the last the last I
guess that was for
that privatized data is a big problem
because then the auditing will become
impossible and so nobody should be
willing to work with privatized data and
there should be a constant demand for at
least access for public and the last is
that who designs the problem is pretty
central right and so the the
participatory or governance
accountability structures for problem
design are central so those that's what
I heard is that accurate am I missing
something and take for example on the
gene genomic data is it only genomic
data that has this problem where are
there others we're working on blood now
[Laughter]
I mean right now there's a ton of work
happening on the microbiome
for example racial you name it
heterogeneous and it's all to be
discovered right now but but to see it
not as a product of the individuals
themselves but the context and also how
that relates to the food systems of the
different parents around food systems
that people are in let alone also what's
going into the waste water which is
really important which has to do a lot
with the antibiotics they're going on in
different countries and different
antibiotic wounds and what's happening
in agriculture in cows producing
injected with the antibiotics so you
can't imagine a microbiome without
thinking about
thanks for that and the same would apply
to the epigenetics research as well in
terms of trying to figure out so I think
that you'll see that anything that is an
ohmic and or a bio which are being
politically shaped and so that's the
frame bring to it and I would not just
say genomics alone right exactly
so anything I think you're right that
it's something about biological
explanations for the social problems
that they're interested in addressing
that needs to be really scrutinized and
contextualized even even those new ways
of thinking about social inequality
affecting biology as opposed to biology
producing social inequalities poverty
but they still often end up as
biological exploitation developmental
sciences are a way of sort of saying how
these species even speciate let alone
what individuals do whenever up being a
member of their species or subspecies
anyway but if you don't understand
context you don't understand the biology
and you don't understand the expression
of biology at the time says things in
threes so I was you're either half is
interested in about the board or twice
as interested so what's going on here so
anyway that's neither here nor there
what I I thought your list was awesome
and you'll just pick up on one bit you
said cuz I think that's one thing around
getting data so that lots can compete on
it I think if I look outside of Health
if you look at the cars reality work
it's shocking the thin data it's based
on and that's not anyone's fault it's
just that's not available Marcy and I
are involved in something and help to
try to break through it you said we
should I thought her thing of vision and
speech was a great great way to see the
difference beautiful ways you different
but I think the efforts being undertaken
also illustrate what the bottleneck is
which is ultimately putting these data
together is just a public good there's
just a lot of work so over the last few
months a project called Nightingale but
nevertheless so the idea is why should
big private providers that we won't name
but who rhyme with Google why should
they go and acquire these private data
and then kind of not be able to share
it's like how will the community
progress so we've been going to
hospitals and health systems and saying
what if you were trying let us do all
the data engineer and then put up some
of your data
security platform for research use and
I'll say that we've I mean you don't
want to count chickens before they
happen but we certainly got some eggs
we've gotten we've gotten enough
interest from enough Health Systems that
I think it's actually promising and I
think there's information there which is
I think if people in this room are
willing to pay the sweat equity if
funders are willing to pay the dollar
equity I do think that in these areas
and it's not much if you think in the
grand scheme of things it's what said
the economy so you know a tiny drop in
the human capital and financial capital
of it I think in many of these areas I'm
sorry
we're on such a tight schedule and this
panel yes that's what I was going to
suggest I think if you would please put
your questions on Cynthia have to work
this out then did the nice motion okay
we can do that Matt may I suggest
something I was going to suggest that
actually yeah okay okay okay this is
definitely representative of the Harvard
MIT class schedules at MIT they start
like 10 minutes like nobody cares what I
was going to suggest is that those who
have unanswered question questions
please put them on these and then we'll
make some time we also have some extra
time at the end in which we are going to
address those questions which are which
still hang and most people not everybody
but most people will still be here by
the end and so that might be a way to
resolve the question of hunger versus
estimates so why don't we why don't we
just call it a day right now and by the
next session we will have worked out a
better system of back and forth around
the questioning
[Applause]